okay so this is a real thoughts on the
cell yes sir I already told them what we
were doing no surprise on this one ah
well it's kind of a surprise we only
talked about it like two minutes ago
yeah that is true
we're just looking through what which
one to do we're like yeah we just did
review and scooby-dooby kind of slide
just to do that now so my god a cell we
put that up recently so let's talk about
that cuz that's an interesting I
interesting movie to talk about actually
you would be not surprised because I
really fucking hate this movie
suspicious you know and I I review it
first saw oh yeah I'm an I'll let you
finish first am i interrupting yeah
sisters you dragged me to this fucking
movie
so now that was infamous of this like
ash it's like a short list maybe ten
films in my life that Doug is like
dragged me to that I will never forgive
him for and this was another one of
those like spider-man three you insisted
was better than the first two x-men
saying that x-men three one of the
greatest films ever made uh and like it
Little Nicky which you did no no no no
behind you like that one but yeah that
never fails one dance and we could make
little nickel and we were literacies
which is like nope you didn't like Italy
so I don't have to argue you on that but
you did drag me to see it and we could
have seen Red Planet which would not
have been a great movie but what about a
lot fucking better than that least we
saw the worst we saw like the worst of
that year we can say that paid money to
see my hard-earned money and in the cell
this is another one that um yeah the
this one I saw you know I honestly I'll
be very honest I saw this movie cuz
their inner pretentious no I school fake
kinda I like I got no no because it had
like it got bad reviews but then Ebert
was phrasing the hell out of it I'm like
hat but we knew he's kind of a sucker
for eye candy so we went and saw this
movie and you know I came out and I just
I couldn't figure out him like was this
I couldn't put a finger print out I
couldn't figure out what to classify it
so I can't brought you along because I
was like what is visually really
interesting you know and Candace Biggs
free and I just I couldn't play
no no it was one of those things where I
was like I just kind of wanted a second
opinion odd you know it's like it's one
of the few times where I'm like I need
to know what second opinion you're also
crazy uh it was one of those were it's
just I needed someone else to talk about
just to help me kind of I don't want say
form an opinion but I just couldn't yeah
I couldn't form an opinion that really
was kind of it doe a cause that was in a
format for you it stinks well so then
you came out here just like that sucked
and we just kind of talked about for a
bit and I'm still kind of a little open
to it but I knew you were right as well
and years went by and then just
rewriting this a bit he had an actual
picture of tarsem in his room as an
altar he gave it offerings of like
fruits and sweetmeats um and so we may
have exaggerated a bit oh it was just
fruit not meat
so this movie is seen by us again years
later comes a thing of this and people
are talking about like yes really good
film really good like just right
ethically a no like this has like kind
of like a following and I guess kind of
people can like the Ebers and stuff that
I don't want say fell for it but this
film it's not taking advantage you know
this film it's not taking advantage of
the setup that has and instead is trying
to go very much for the shock value and
the confusing as I put it ask me what it
means value uh that I feel like even
though maybe the directors very nice I
don't know I feel like there's kind of
that eco-centric
Ness going on where it's like it's about
how do I make a style how do I make you
look at me and say what's going on in
his mind uh and I know that because I
was that person for several years and
that's exactly what I thought I thought
I want to make art but I want people to
look at me and say what's going on his
mind I want to analyze you I just wanted
the attention so I'm not saying it's
necessary what's going on some people
never grow but I'll be nice but I think
with this I just get that from the whole
time because I feel like there's a lot
you could analyze with it and I think of
something but not necessarily hammer
hammer it in either and I think a good
example is something like sounds of the
Lambs
now that doesn't have to
physically go inside a killers mind but
we technically go inside two killers one
that's very articulate and incan speak
very well and another who is just very
kind of just put the lotion just kid put
the law and ease he's the more realistic
so yeah the thoughtful Oh bill is
definitely more definitely yeah I love
Hannibal as a character but he's more of
a movie mods yeah and we like she's like
a Bond villain you know but um Buffalo
Bills one those characters were it so
you're still going inside his mind and
trying to figure out there's a lot of
things going on even though you visually
don't show it you know air is and they
talk about it and they talk about just
the right amount as well so I feel like
that stuff that you could have done here
and I like the idea it seemed like it's
doing a lot show don't tell but you know
even the telling was very obvious and
the showing was very obvious except when
just cuts to random strange things that
they really really focus on for a while
and then be like oh the horse being cut
in a million pieces and stuff you know
uh-huh okay figure that out uh-huh it's
like well can't you sure some fucked up
weird thing and the jeffer Lopez with
like the cloth with Jesus's face on it
just get ha ha ah ha try to figure that
and it's you don't want to and I had
symbolic of Jennifer Lopez believing
she's bigger than Jesus sister and I
think a big part of that I brought in
the review is that we don't get to know
deny DNF Rios character uh we only get
to know when we go inside the mind but
we don't know what this I know more
about Wilson Fisk as deny don't carried
I ever did about I didn't remember this
guy's fuckin name ya know and here's who
I uh and yet we're supposed to go in
science might say oh poor guy poor guy
but all we saw of him in the real world
this is angels looking at some dead
women and just being like oh it gives me
heart and like nothing else well it was
the most ins and the evil Buffalo Bill I
felt like he was like when Jodie Foster
hold on yeah yeah bill about what he was
was socially awkward he was good
amalgamation of like three series serial
killers did but it felt real he was
living this kind of scuzzy slimy life in
this like you know kind of dirt poor
house he just reconfigured his basement
you know his only real
quirk well I mean he's making a human
skin suit but his his only real quirk is
like the moths and stuff you know even
even red dragon I felt red dragon was a
little uh a man Hunter was a little
overwrought with the serial killers
actions I need the moonlight and the you
know it was kind of crated but even then
I felt like it was a little more
grounded
I feel like post silent slams up this is
this was a huge problem for a while it's
like every serial killer needs some sort
of artistic sort of edge they're gonna
be weird and this guy's gonna like like
hang himself on various chains with the
various and it's so crazy insane that
I'm just like I just can't buy this for
a second
I feel like this is just so beyond them
like first up where's he getting the
fucking money to do all this where it
just ah well and on top of that you know
I think there was something where this
whole moon this is why I think the movie
really has an aged well you know on top
of right after it came out but even the
visual style with the exception of the
costumes cuz those are some of the best
ever see in my life that's the same
person who did like branch chokers
Dracula and Stefan's famous designer for
getting the actual production design is
good I don't like it but here's the
thing with the production design I
realized watching it years later at the
time it was like wow that's a intriguing
but now you kind of feel like you you've
seen it everywhere like with Marilyn
Manson a lot of music videos and nothing
like videos but it was implied and
suddenly you realize it was emblematic
it was emblematic of its time I mean so
it is dated but I can't say that it was
awful production design in the fact that
there was no effort that went into oh no
no but no you're right which is part but
that's what I'm saying at that time that
was so in like serial killers in this
weird artistic inner mind and it's super
nice see this shit on things like you
know I'll flip on some random station
you'll get an episode of CSI where it's
just like this serial killer recreated
his childhood home like right down to
every last detail and then prison a
woman in there and then like did all
these things and ended up mummifying her
and then like created like took a piece
of her skin and then created a Mona Lisa
and at some point it's like okay like
would just kill somebody
I just fucking kill somebody and just
get your bucket sexual jollies and just
be done like it's so insanely like over
I would love to see what you just
described I'm not gonna lie just they
always making the motorway I always see
the Sun chosen after well okay I love
Silence of the Lambs I love but the
impact they've had on like serial killer
films to me that's one of the negatives
about it yeah it's like they all fall
under this you know mad twisted genius
and I'm what ya t'east yeah and not to
say those people aren't I don't want to
say artists or anything but you know but
that type of killer isn't out there but
there's a lot more of them in the movies
and we really seem to like this guy to
me was the ultimate work with che
example of it I can't think about all
he's missing is completion can you airy
vocabularies he needs he needs a large
extensive vocabulary and references to
like Shakespeare or something but or
like fucking Voltaire and lay that
that's it otherwise like it is the most
cliched fucking serial killer I've ever
seen of this type in a movie well and
you brought up daredevil with um you
know the kingpin and I'm just thinking
like cuz this is literally the guy that
played yeah - two killers that I was
sighs do because I'm a huge Vincent
D'Onofrio fan so when I saw he was in
this movie I'm like yes this will be
amazing I mean when I got a head movie I
was like no that fucking suck and I'm
thinking like yeah one really a fella
with fists they really dived into his
childhood and such and this movie did -
but with Fisk there is something about
you know what he becomes you know what
it leads to and you have an idea what
he's like we're with this guy you really
don't you just see inside his mind and
all they really don't know next to it
outside of his hands never he is there
was no step in between step a get beat
up as a child step B become monstrous
insane genius artistic serial killer
there was no explanation in between Fisk
you feel like the background story
informs you of how he becomes his
character he is there that step was
missing here it's just learned just like
why do you do this I got beat as a child
okay a lot of people get beat as a child
where's the missing step like just
because you get beat as a child doesn't
mean that you're going to become a
serial killer there's a series of things
that
happen in your wife that lead from one
point to another and all of those other
steps see missing it was just like okay
you got beat as a child but what but I
just didn't inform me of anything about
his character and really the okay my
biggest time with the film is it's just
two separate things one is a really
shitty police procedural like with with
Vince Vaughn yeah I'm gonna stop himself
just chain-smoking I like another
question all those cliche yeah we're
gonna stop him cuz he ain't gonna stop
himself there's a million I get in the
review we point out like all the plot
holes I'm Vince Vaughn by the way as
technology is supposed to work this
great police force and all that and in
Vince Vaughn one of the great comedic
actors and a dramatic dramatic actor I
can ever take snow okay I can't do it
I'm sorry sir
I cannot do it um I love him in so many
comedies I think he's a great comedian I
I just
whenever he's doing drama I know yeah
I'm so there's that one so it's a shitty
bad CSI film and then on top of that a
really shitty postmodern art display
that you pass through in the museum and
go like wow there's a lot of fucked up
people in the world yeah and then you
just leave the museum and you've
forgotten most of what you've seen like
the dissected horse and then it's just
it's a bad modern artists you know if I
feel like it doesn't really connect or
tie into anything it's just walking
through the but the monitors knowing
whirring that way that's what I feel
like I feel like this movie is a million
excuses about why I can get away with
stuff that everyone else in the world
can plainly see what it's trying to do
what it's trying to be but it
technically has excuses to do it reminds
me of when I went to the Art Institute
of Chicago and they have a modern art
wing and I'm not gonna rip on all modern
art because that you know I go through
the modern art wing and there's some
things I'm like wow this is really cool
this really speaks to me then you get
about maybe at least 50% of the shit in
there that you're just like now this is
garbage
like total garbage and some idiot at the
instance you've paid money they have is
on display like it's just ridiculous but
I remember like there are a couple
things where it's just like one was like
a display of like a baby hanging by a
string and there's like an anchor on the
ground and it's like this is 911
so you get shit like that and then
there's my favor was there was another
one where was just this dark room and
some guy dressed as a clown with a porno
mag sitting on the toilet just fapping
and if you walk through all of that in
about 20 minutes and then just watch an
episode of CSI there's the set that's it
it's my experience at the modern art
wing of the Art Institute across with
watching a shitty episode of CSI on the
way home
well in what I felt this film Ameri we
talked about this one first came out to
is that uh the contrast between reality
and the world inside his mind there's
not that big a contrast I feel it's a
big missed opportunity because if you
have like the real world
something like sounds of the Lambs it's
kind of gritty and kind of you know like
you almost feel like you're really there
and then you go inside the world of his
mind it is also real and weird how would
have been more of interest how much more
interest like this reality is so beyond
bizarre ease feel like no even the way
c'mon yeah it is shot like how it shot
in the dream world and when you rating
himself out drowning the woman in the
giant will you get a tank that like this
is so many things I'm like no his normal
life is so bizarre that it just just
it's like okay so his Majan life is just
a little screwy but not by much even in
sounds on the lands when you see Buffalo
Bills you know little dungeon area and
stuff like that I mean that a pretty
bizarre life and prey bizarre mine but
it's shot kind of like you're there
looking at it and if he is target if you
have some kind the thing is it feels
starting uncomfortable because it's not
like he built himself a real dungeon
it's just a shitty basement well I mean
that's what makes it creepy like with
just a fucking pit what and even down to
you know like what they wear when they
go inside his mind even though those
suits were cool and dreamlike there's no
reason for them to look that way they
just want a cool production yeah no
that's my saying that's it there should
be that separation because then we go
inside that world it's like oh it's so
different it's so weird it's like in the
ex like that we always said we always
say an exorcist we like you know there's
an extra scene the edit where the
goes outside the room and we said now we
like that that room was the scary place
when you go in there it's like yeah it's
a gem world and that was something where
I feel they really miss that in this and
could have been really interesting
because if this is a great idea in my
opinion that the idea of literally go
inside a killers mind why saw the poster
even why saw the trailers I'm like this
sounds like a brilliant idea I can't
wait to see what they do with this um
and then when you also have these stars
event there let's say they weren't big
names at the time you know or whatever
they look like they're big stars it
looks like the classic cop that's just
smoking the cigarette brushing his teeth
in the office the nice psychiatrist who
just wants to talk but oh this be creepy
mind uh and the people you know they're
just help him like you know I need you
here no don't you understand exposition
exposition exposition and then the
cliche killer you know so you never feel
like it's a contrast between this
fantasy world in his mind and this real
world cuz you are never in the real
world and I would argue never even fully
in the dream world either you're
constantly interrupted by either what is
trying to be said or what's being
excused as trying to say something
I just felt no connection to any of the
characters including the woman he's
gonna kill who just is just some random
character just okay and he's gonna
slowly drown her in the end i eggy you
kind of watch it just like okay like you
know she's gonna make it out like I even
okay okay I hate to keep going back to
this sounds the lamps the girl in that
well in that pit I felt like oh that was
a much personality precious are you up
there you little shit sure you you want
this dog you better come down to yeah I
just like there was in on that that
scene to where she sees like the
fingernails broken off on the side of
then she's like haha the bumper her way
more interesting than anything we got
here ya know it's I hate to keep going
back to that but let's be honest the
cell kept going back to it so I think we
can nobody just they literally just kept
cutting back to as if just like hey just
a reminder I guess there's a point to
this shit like I can't feel like you
know actually a good comparison
kind of in the same realm sound cell
lands versus Hannibal Hannibal is a
completely different mill memory ahead
sounds about know it Hannibal the first
case good no place but even then from
the beginning of the film you know this
is not Silence of them that's true that
this is an artsy beautiful looking film
and she it's the opposite it's when that
film is not being Silence of the Lambs
when it's in Florence and artistic and
weird that it's it's best when it goes
back to Virginia the movie just
completely yeah when it's trying to be a
real silly serial killer movie you know
it doesn't work as its so in this
different realm and I think they're
missing something when you need the
first parts like an Italian horror film
and it just turns in another serial
killer movie it's like but with pigs
yeah um so yeah I think there's anything
else say about this movie I mean I think
the majority of is there do you I still
be only the guy remember it is do
diddily i do do that that's my favorite
part of him in that movie everything
else is him just go oh yeah rule of the
ladder over here yeah he's legitimately
like what the fuck are you right now is
it he's just singing his song wouldn't
you try favorites is that mcsoley such
entertaining a man yeah um although we
got do that stupid thing where it's like
you know your name is doctor so-and-so
you have a kid named blah blah blah and
like decently - oh that's me and it's
just yeah okay wait a second cyclist
Shaye's to get in this way he'll kill
her arias miss I guess that's also
bothers me is this serial killers is
beyond fucked up and yet this train
psychiatrist goes in and immediately
just crumbles like a you know fucking
house ik alike just topples like a house
of cards and it needs to be talked out
by the the cop whose only real function
seems to be the chain-smoke a drink like
I'm just like really who's the trained
psychiatrist here like it's just I yeah
I think there's something where even
like when there is confrontation it's
always it isn't I mean how little is
there I'll see real talking to him and
then seeing visual representation
I got oh oh I got it yeah we got got it
have been a better movie if it was like
something like fucking Clarice Starling
or another like psychiatrist going into
Hannibal's head cuz ELISA it's two
psychiatrist versus each other I could
see how one would really dominate the
other but I couldn't see it with these
two characters good posing in the
beginning it's like oh she's supposed to
be like so good at this and like I don't
know what and pretty much all there is
in this movie is that he got beaten as a
kid you know and abuse it's it's like
that's really it and we're supposed to
be like you know oh and she distant
whatever didn't get it Oh crying but
it's like what so he is beaten that
really sucks but again we can't connect
again so in the beginning she got
outwitted by the kids psyche in the I
know I don't get how these like dream
worlds work where it says like you would
think the adult who's got the better
grip on their own brain would be able to
like figure this out but she gets like
bested by a kid in the beginning doesn't
she like is she's in a cabin it's like
that just the bad side of the prank cuz
that's what the movies saying everybody
just has a bad side that's eating the
good side a brilliant psychology well
you got it it's just fucking Carl Jung
for dummies it's like there's a shadow
self and that's in there and then they
end their discussion there and it's just
but it's like I mean you could totally
like fucking it Pitons like paprika
inception like there's a number of films
and stuff that could like do this better
and have honestly that I will say the
cells only contribution maybe this is it
may have given other people an idea like
oh I can do something like this only it
won't suck yeah like I got so much
better um so maybe I should give it some
credit for doing that because what I'm
thinking about I'm like that was one
that earlier wants to do kind of this
shit it was just terrible at it I don't
know just the whole thing I think with
the cliches with the style with the
total lack of focus everything I see in
it does not point to I really want to
show you you know the mind of a serial
killer and the background and the life
and stuff it I want to show you what I
can do with something and I want you to
praise me for it that's what I always oh
yeah and and even if I'm wrong even if
this doers are real nice doing
really thought he was bringing something
that is how it comes across and I think
there is a fear and execution one way or
another yeah I mean mm yeah whatever I
say that not saying that's what the
person is I don't know what the person
is like but I'm saying then how it comes
across I think that's a failure on the
film this is I think this is a problem
with this type of movie in genre which
is I bet if you talk to most behavioral
psychologists or behavioral profile ways
they will tell you the inside mind of a
serial killer is probably not as
fascinating as you would think it's
probably just a lot of sexual perversion
and just getting their jollies from you
know manipulating people and killing
people and but it's like this sort of
highly insane artistic imaginary fantasy
world with the medieval paintings and
the I feel like that would probably be
more rare I think most times it's just
probably thinking like how can I get my
sexual jollies by strangling this girl
or stabbing her in the back related I
feel like that's that's what I tend to
think it's probably gonna be so this
makes this type of movie from the
beginning it's kind of troublesome
because like let's go in the mind of a
serial killer it's like okay don't think
it's gonna be as interesting to non
serial killers it is I think there's
something where it's I think really
wanted to go like abstract like an
abstract style or movie uh you know you
have to get rid of these cliches we see
a million times on these beautiful
people chasing other beautiful people
and stuff I think you need like you know
a David Lynch or a Stanley Kubrick or
somebody thought attack you know if that
can really go abstract and not be like
this equals this now here some we're
going to ask drag now this equals this
and now we're back to the wheel were
just something where it is legitimately
confused you know in a way that's
intentional in a way that you know
blending reality and the dream world can
actually overlap in a way that maybe you
never thought of before I can't really
explain here it's so easy to explain
it's so easy just a point okay we're
doing abstract okay this means something
okay now this part of the real world
supposed to be like this part of the
dream world and it's just so clear that
I feel like if you got someone that
really was going to take more chances
and kind of blur that line more in a way
that's not as obvious and not excelled
out for
you it just comes you know fact I hate
movies like if you're going to okay if
you're just going to make a torture porn
then fine make a torture porn and do
what you do and at least you could say
okay this is just some cheap
exploitation torture porn film if you're
gonna try to make it something better
than that
then it has to mean something or occur
come to some effect this just seem like
a giant waste of time to me um you know
and that's why like I know Weber was
like visually it's really interesting
and isn't that but he also gave Phantom
Menace three-and-a-half stars but
visually it's really interesting and all
that so I this isn't this is why I tell
people like it's not our job as critics
to tell you always is the movie
objectively good or not we're just
telling you our opinion of the film and
this is one of the reasons why because
like I learned from me birds that I'm
like okay he is a sucker for hard candy
he is a hard-on for visuals to a point
that you know you could throw a piece of
shit on screen and he would he gave the
haunting remake three stars yeah cause
he'll know how it looked now to be fair
he was a little more honest with I'm
just really recommending it for the
house but he's usually pretty honest
about that stuff I know there's some
reviews where I had to figure it out
early on where cuz sometimes he wouldn't
mention it I had to figure it out I'm
just like okay this is how he works this
is his brain and I'm sure people were
just like oh you seduced about thick
you're wrong that's fine
watch us consistently if you want to
trust our opinion for some godforsaken
reason you it's your job to watch us
consistently and figure out basically
how our brains are working and how it
meshes with your is it just like well
they normally like this type of movie
and I don't file that away and if we
like that sort of movie again you'd be
like oh well maybe I shouldn't see it
and there was a certain series of films
that Ebert liked where I would see
certain cues in the writing just like oh
we it's really interesting and and oh it
shows me things I haven't seen before
I'm like and if there's no mention of
story along with better
the stories are I'd be like okay this
probably isn't gonna be a movie for me
well what I like about a good critic is
that whether I agree with them or not or
like something they dislike or something
is that a good critic I think can give
you a new point of view you haven't
thought of like I can read something
maybe I was confused about something
I've read someone else's work I
Oh like I never thought of that side to
it or even if I'm watching something
that like I love but someone really
hates and they explain why in a way I'm
like I never thought of that angle
that's actually really intriguing uh so
that's what I like when somebody can do
that so even if there is a critic that
you know you disagree with a lot I think
we both this grooc Bieber and a lot of
stuff I think he could offer a point of
view that suddenly made me go okay
that's actually run there are times
where he said things about films where I
agreed with him totally and I like a new
appreciation for the film because of it
yeah even better I get him far better
um but yeah that this was not one of
them this is always just iwon this is
this is this is one where I'm just like
he's getting all mad out of his mind I
don't know between this cuz this I think
in Phantom Menace we're not that far
apart I was starting to wonder and I was
like okay maybe I just need to readjust
my opinion of Ebert here and well you
just say that like a little a I'm alone
on this like nobody else likes this
movie but you know I think it's one of
the best of the year that's like if that
super guy that that's fine with him the
the Phantom Menace was the big tease for
me where I saw that movie no but every
critic was like kind of praising their
winning oh I know her yeah but then but
then this is where it gets interesting
cuz then in the second film where he's
just like well on the acting's wouldn't
and stiff and I'm just like where are
you on the first half
oh yeah hey after that looking good cuz
attack on clones like I'm like yeah you
didn't like attack of the clones he only
likes it a little bit better and I'm
just like but Fanta this is the
three-and-a-half story okay okay I get a
feeling he looks back on that to just
like you know this is pretty exciting
new Star Wars movie come so far back
here ya know so um yeah that's our
thoughts on the cell if you like it
great um not for us definitely not for
us Oh mute they're great to just if you
like it huh so um this is me and Rob
saying huh if you like it I'll
acknowledge you exist I won't
I won't actively hunt you down
huh you just want to go out of heart
don't you yeah gee we can do it 1 2 3 1
2 3
huh not doing it dick